- Welcome back everybody.
Our next guest's life has
been quite the journey.
He overcame addiction
and living in his car
to become America's motivator
for healthy living and
weight loss, incredible.
He's an author
and was the host of "Extreme Weight Loss."
Now he has a new podcast
called "I Needed That"
all about improving your
life on the inside and out.
It's perfect if you're already trying
to reignite your New Year's resolutions
that you may have already quit by now.
Let's welcome Chris Powell, everybody.
(audience cheering)
So, I'm gonna say this podcast,
is it kinda like a reset for you?
- It is.
I consider it kind of my
second mountain actually
after the show.
You know, I spent 20 years
helping people find themselves
through fitness
and I actually went through my own
difficult mental health battle.
Went through a divorce and saw...
- Oh, me too, yeah.
- It really, I found myself
in a really dark place.
I went through six
therapists in five years,
and I full extreme ownership of it,
I became the worst version of myself.
And I just realized that
it was time to separate
and as I went through that though,
it was just emptiness and
loneliness and all of that.
And so, sure enough, I ended up
realizing the power of mental health
when it comes to transformation.
And so yes, like this whole thing
it really is the second
mountain for myself
just because I can't
have this conversation
about transformation, about
physical health and all that
without talking about mental health
because it's, when you talk,
- It's powerful.
- It's everything in one,
it's a holistic approach
to transformation now.
And so, and I didn't realize that
until going through my own battle
and utilizing different tools
like breathing, gratitude,
and talking about it with other people.
I can't stress that enough.
And that's where the podcast
has become so important for me
'cause it really is,
it's kind of part of my recovery.
- Oh, talking for me is same, I mean,
obviously I have a talk show.
But I just, it's the same thing for me.
That's how I almost figure it out
is by talking with people.
I learn about myself while hearing myself
say something aloud like,
"Wait, did I mean that?
Or did I, what, what does that?"
And also, with mental health
I think people think like,
"Oh, you know, you're sad."
The hardest part is you
don't know you're depressed
or sad sometimes, you don't catch it
and you can't recognize that at first.
And so, that's when I talk to someone too
like during my divorce
and still do because it's
really healthy, I think,
to have somebody outside your circle.
But you launched, I wanna talk about this
'cause you also launched a nonprofit.
So can you tell us a
bit about that and why?
- So, service.
You know, service,
especially when you're going
through a difficult time,
you spend so much time
thinking about yourself,
but you realize like how powerful it is
when you start to serve others.
And that was one of the biggest things
that really helped me find myself again.
And it was in the middle of
the pandemic and quarantine.
People weren't moving,
and obviously mental health
issues were through the roof.
And I was so inspired by
something that happened in Japan.
This is a crazy story.
Back in 1928.
They mandated three and a
half minutes of movement
done to music.
It's movement and music together.
And it was the same 13
movements done to the same music
every day, every factory, every
school, every corporation.
They all moved at the same time.
And in one generation, Japan
became the healthiest country
in the world and they united.
- What?
- Yes, it's called rajio taiso,
it means radio calisthenics.
It's powerful.
It changed the country.
- It's 13 movements
and it's only like a couple
minutes every morning?
- It's three and a half minutes long.
And I was so inspired by that.
And sure enough, here
we are, 94 years later,
27 million still do rajio
taiso every single day
and they continue to be the
healthiest country in the world.
And I was like, we need this now.
- I need this now, what?
- Yes, we do.
- I wanna know these movements, yeah.
- I started my nonprofit Move 1 Million,
and it's two and a half minutes
because who's got three and a
half minutes nowadays, right?
So it's 13 movements just to pay tribute
to the 13 from Japan.
But yeah, I created the music.
I actually wrote and
played the music for it.
And I take us, it's a total
body warmup, top to bottom.
And I mean, it's absolutely,
the impact that it's had.
Schools have started adopting it.
We launched it in 2021.
Schools have been adopting it, hospitals.
We've got 100,000 people
moving in 71 countries now
for two and a half minutes a day.
And it's been incredible.
- I think that's incredible.
It's so simple, yet effective.
- That's it.
- Yeah.
- Lower the barrier of
entry and sure enough
and everyone can do it.
And a body in motion
tends to remain in motion.
- I'm gonna do this
and you're gonna come back
and I'm gonna be like, so changed.
- Oh, I love it.
In fact, have me back and
I wanna move everybody.
We'll have a blast.
Two and a half minutes.
- I'm down for that.
I think that's cool.
- Let's go.
- Well, Chris's podcast "I Needed That"
co-hosted by Matthew Blades
is available on all streaming
platforms, everybody.